comment ça va Cyril j'ai une petite
question pour vous est-ce que vous aimez
tout ce qui est royauté
je commence pas sur regarder cette
petite
extrait de cœur
le 6 mai je dois y aller tout le monde
va en parler sur place la veille le
vendredi non devant withmster on annonce
une répétition le roi sera à 10 mètres
tu vas y aller pour faire quoi bah pour
dire je suis devant will Smither c'est
dans quelques heures le roi t'a dit mais
il répète rappelons ouais ah ouais je
m'en bats le cul je m'en bats
bah oui je sais bien mais les choses
je suis bien sûr j'ai aucune chance
quand même
une bonne idée pourtant c'est honnête
la bienveillance
vous avez décidé de sévir avec vos
chroniqueurs pour leur confisquant leur
téléphone portable parce que c'est pas
normal que les chroniqueurs et leurs
téléphones autour de la table et bien
regardez je voudrais mis j'ai regardé
l'émission hier même si j'étais pas je
regarde toujours vous avez prévenu pas
de portable et j'ai vu celui de la
banque
[Applaudissements]
normalement les règles c'est les règles
sauf pour Mathieu l'ado révolté regardez
il est revenu picassophone pendant la
pub heureusement l'employé du mois
vraiment et là pour remettre les choses
en or
mais personne là
[Musique]
je suis délégué du personnel
et crois-moi tu auras recommandé dans ta
boîte aux lettres
il est content d'être viré les délégué
du personnel des magons
plus 76
encore des relations avec les hautes
sphères de ce monde j'ai tout viré j'ai
toujours demandé c'est bon c'est bon
c'est un muscu ensemble directement
et ce n'est pas fini Matthieu est revenu
défier votre autorité Cyril en piquant
son téléphone avant de reprendre
l'antenne et ça c'est moche la tête de
ma mère elle a repris son téléphone à la
soirée n'importe quoi
[Applaudissements]
on a d'autres choses oui alors ce que
vous buvez a été synonyme du Rix vous
allez voir ça dans un instant oui ça a
été l'objet de tous les de tous les de
tous les problèmes cette semaine
j'utilise un petit peu comme ça
Guillaume sentimentalement comment vous
êtes en ce moment
Chine pendant les pubs et vous savez
qu'il aide et vous savez qu'il aide à
junior dans mon fils
donne-nous les 20 ans merci
Cyril avait fait tout le
tram qui
regarde
c'est mon effet c'est une crêperie à
côté de chez moi
connaissez-vous la définition du mot
forceur la voici en images
bon après les crêpes le tuto drague de
gum Genton se poursuit avec un petit peu
dur politique
[Musique]
et enfin connaissez-vous la définition
du mot déni la voici
salut ma vie
quelqu'un est le boulot
c'est ma position
autour de cette table
alors
le problème c'est que l'autre j'ai pas
envie de donner c'est vraiment un ami
plutôt quand même
et bien c'est là qu'on voit que non le
patron connaît bien ses employés puisque
c'est plus Jean-Michel c'est le roi de
la 15 vraiment regardez vraiment là
accueilli très très chaleureusement
c'est la chaleur humaine ah mais les
bidou de la nouvelle chroniqueuse
aurait-elle peut-être tapé dans l'oeil
de notre petit Raymond
bien sûr
la darka et les boules
tu as vu Dubaï j'ai fait
[Musique]
les appartements
mais il a pas une image alors merde
sur le bateau et regarder un petit peu
parce qu'il y avait une lumière qui
était exactement dans la table je lui ai
demandé juste avant je dis est-ce qu'il
y a les leds ce que tu pourrais me les
remplacer il est en train de regarder si
bien sûr
je regarde tout le monde entier
avant de partir Cyril figurez-vous qu'il
y a eu plusieurs faits divers dans cette
émission cette semaine et vous n'aviez
pas été au courant mais rassurez-vous
qui dit faits divers dit Michel Marie il
est venu vous raconter tous les faits
divers c'est passé ce sont passés cette
semaine dans l'émission C'est dark
unités
lorsque Benjamin Castaldi commet sur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est content en plus 20h30 lorsque une
Rick est éclate sur le plateau le même
Benjamin Castaldi Matthieu Delormeau ont
failli en découdre tout ça à cause d'un
jus de fruits
[Musique]
ensemble
le lendemain il est 19h34 peut-être
19h35 lorsque Anthony non voyant envoie
une punchline qui est malheureusement
pas inaperçu le reste c'est mes mains
mon corps si je suis comme ça donc oui
le regard bien sûr
c'est pour ça que j'ai pas d'amis
18h41 le lendemain selon mes
informations Mathieu Delormeau fait une
proposition à son supérieur hiérarchique
qui le décline très poliment
à ce que je pensais peut-être TPMP
[Applaudissements]
vous voyez ce qu'elle prend comme parfum
de glace Castaldi comme il voit rien
[Rires]
en plus
le meilleur
le meilleur du panier d'eau c'est le a
dedans
merci en tout cas merci Sacha merci
[Applaudissements]